something hey you doing
worry abouts good to see you again good
to see you too I say the last time just
whatever you whatever you think will
make me look we were broke
growing up my mom used to come in
Hanover and it was like taking three
hours to cut my hair should I put the
bolo on and cut all the way around and
take the bowl off and would always been
length it was like the worst haircut
ever
I don't have a call for four years you
haven't taken the bus in LA you should
take it it's a great experience
dude look at this little front part that
they shave it's a lot and it was left
I know lost 20 of the 25 pounds I gained
this season in fact last time I was in
here getting a haircut
he was like goodness your face is so
round and I love doing those sorts of
things I think everyone on our show bald
is portraying a character that changes I
think it's real and I think it's an
important part of our life looking at
the Muni Don Draper looking at himself
in the mirror you know you you see
yourself age you see yourself grow you
see the things that you've done X
themself across your face you know Matt
Winer said something first season he
said because exact thing about our show
is that people don't
not everyone's dress you know our first
season not only was dress 1960 you don't
wake up like are your clothes from 2012
no you know like most the time you'll
have one or two things from this year
but most your stuff from last year or
the year before or five years or ten
years report and especially with man
your clothes are old you know
so Bertram Cooper is wearing stuff from
the 1940s and even if he's not wearing
stuff in the 1940s he's wearing it in
the fashion of the night
towards you know in 1930s and Roger
Sterling's more in the fashions of the
50s you know he okay a little more
fashion forward because he yell in the
beginning but now his closet sold his
closet seven years old surprisingly I
look pretty darn good with math - I
think right now we're stepping to go
back in October if Pete Campbell comes
back this funky when you never know you
never know which characters are are not
going to come back you never know where
we're going to be you never know what
year it's going to be we know as much as
everyone else which is absolutely
nothing and to be honest I like it that
way